كان هذا شهرًا قويًا من التوظيف هنا ،
وهذا هو النوع الأخير من الرقم الاقتصادي الذي
يتجه إلى منتصف المدة
ويخبرنا أنه تم تعديل صافي 250 ألف وظيفة جديدة في
شهر أكتوبر ،
لكنني لن أشعر
بالقلق حيال ذلك  كان إعصار
فلورنسا وكان هناك بعض
المشكلات المتعلقة بالطقس ولكن انظر إلى شهر أغسطس الذي تمت مراجعته
أعلى هنا ،
لذا فأنت ترى توظيفًا قويًا للغاية من
الشركات الأمريكية وهذا يحافظ
على معدل البطالة هنا منخفضًا بالقرب
من هذا الجيل المنخفض بنسبة 3.7٪.
من الأشياء التي
تهتمون بها يا رفاق زيادة الأجور بنسبة
3.1 في المائة مما يؤكد الرقم الذي
رأيناه في وقت سابق من هذا الأسبوع نمو الأجور الآن بدأ
أخيرًا في مقياس آخر كان
نمو الأجور بأسرع وتيرة هذا
العام منذ عشر سنوات ومعدل البطالة
هذا كان سيذهب  أقل ، ربما
لم يكن هناك 700000 شخص دخلوا سوق العمل
وهذا عدد كبير ومن المحتمل
أيضًا أنه يعكس التوظيف في الإجازات ، دعني أوضح
لك ما هي القطاعات الترفيهية
والكثير من ذلك هو تلك
الوظائف التي نتحدث عنها في مجال المطاعم
وما شابه ذلك في مجال الرعاية الصحية
36000 تصنيع 32000 وهذا
رقم مهم يجب ذكره هناك أريد
أن أرى ما تفعله الأسواق
لأننا نتوقع نوعًا من اليوم الكبير  هنا ،
ارتفع مؤشر داو في الأيام الثلاثة الماضية
بمقدار 900 نقطة تقريبًا ، لذا فقد كانت
رحلة متقلبة للغاية هنا هذه الأرقام على
الرغم من أنها تظهر لك سوق عمل
قوي جدًا